and the lights of Hollywood could soon
be coming and shining in Las Vegas as
the Nevada legislature debates its
largest tax break package ever to bring
Productions to town now we know the
second location of a potential Film
Studio but is 8 news now reporter Ryan
Matthey shows us some neighbors are not
ready for the spotlight
did Caesar live here
um no a scene on screen you might soon
see in Las Vegas the Mandalorian right
shot entirely in a green room
Productions Howard Hughes Corporation
CEO David O'Reilly envisions in southern
Nevada as SB 496 makes its way through
the Nevada legislature it if passed it
becomes the largest tax break in State
history offering up to 190 million in
tax breaks each year to Production
Studios to access the 190 million
dollars of tax credits it will take
633 million dollars of content creation
the bill is also structured that over 50
percent of the below the line costs need
to be local employees or you don't have
access to the credit
a studio location in the southwest
Valley was announced weeks ago that
would also serve as an education
pipeline for UNLV film students further
up the valley in South Summerlin Howard
Hughes core and Sony Pictures
envisioning at least half a million
square feet of Studios joined with a
mixed-used retail space and a potential
Hotel the Summerlin Studios could be on
these 60 acres of land that currently
has a furniture store some offices and a
lot of dirt but it's the neighbors who
surround this property who say they
don't want a movie studio in their
backyard and others who say they can't
wait to join in well it's a lot better
than a prison despite what it could be
neighbors like Joe Ellen Goforth are
concerned with noise I just picture a
lot of late night shooting
losing our views While others like Lou
gehrenbrand see their dreams of working
in the movies come to life I think it's
awesome that we can see something that
possibly you get the chance to help with
and then put onto the big screen this is
a tax credit that's only earned when
people spend dollars
now the legislative session ends on
Monday the bill would need to be passed
by then to avoid a special session when
Ryan asked the CEO about missing that
deadline he said quote one hurdle at a
time